imagine making a sculpture so tiny your
eyelash is the paintbrush creating
pieces in the eyes of needles a canvas
one third the size of a fruit fly's Wing
that's the daily experience of this man
my name is Willard Wigan I'm the Creator
the smallest handmade sculptures in
history
this is more complicated than any micro
surgery I don't care what anybody says
you have to have a more stable hand than
any surgeon to do this work this one
took me a long time four months because
each Camel had to individually put in an
individually made at about to serrate
the needles at the bottom scrape it away
so you got this Jagged edges underneath
and then press their feet into the bit
that I've serrated if I ever needed
psychiatric help I think it was probably
this one because the camels are jumping
and sticking to the top of the needle
through static and pushing them back
down and see how thin the legs are how
did I make those legs without them
falling off that was one of the hardest
things I've ever done in truth every
piece is impossibly difficult because
they're susceptible to the slightest of
disturbances I was making Alice in
Wonderland and when I make my sculptures
I normally lift them and put them into
position so when Alice was made I lifted
Alice like that to sit in the chair
behind the table and my mobile phone
went off and I went
who's that and as I breathe in I inhaled
Alice gone somewhere in my cavities
somewhere
but it was a blessing disguise because I
made another Alice which was better than
the first one
these tiny marbles require a steady hand
but also a steady mind prepared to
weather the microcosmic elements before
I start work I'll do breathing exercises
I can feel my heart pumping away
I can feel myself being really steady I
can feel it and once I get closer to the
microscope all my fingers together I can
feel the poles in my finger and I can
feel when it stops and then I'll work
between the pulse feet that's what I do
when I'm working I am in a state of I
have to do this right and it tires me
out because I may do 16 out of 17 hours
or even longer sometimes it's impossible
to enjoy it because nobody enjoys
holding that breath
first step I have to cut out a rough
shape of what I'm about to create and
then once I've cut out that rough shape
I'll go back and have a look at it but
I've got to turn that rough shape into
what I want it to look like and that is
a bit where little problems can occur
I would say 20 I get rid of 80 makes its
completion sometimes I'll make something
up in my head and then it doesn't quite
turn out right two weeks into it I'll
pick it up and say I don't like that a
little further away
to carefully make something so
incredibly small Willard needs his own
specialized tools
this one here is a hypodermic needle
very fine needle one of the finest you
can get and what I've done I've cut the
needle off to shorten it and what I do
when I'm doing a sculpture if I was
carving an animal or something like that
I'd put a piece of material into the
hole of the needle then manipulate it
around and slice and separate the
material that I'm carving like putting
the carrot almost
and this second one here has got a
little blade it's like an engraving tool
very hard Steel
a third one it's like a hook and it's
twirled at the end and that hook enables
me to manipulate and move and twist
things around when you look at it
underneath the microscope they look a
bit crude looking but they do the job
this one here is a paintbrush my eyelash
is stuck on the end of that so that's
pretty simple
and this one this is like a little drill
so I drill little holes so if I'm
drilling a hole I just press onto the
material and I just keep turning it back
as a rotating backwards and forwards but
very very gently till I make a little
hole if I have to this one is like a
claw and what it does it grabs things I
can hold things with it and it can pick
things up it's got this little end on it
that can grab if you can't buy these
tools
possible you have to make them yourself
with these small implements the scope of
work Willer can do is truly staggering
this one here is the smallest sculpture
any human being has ever made by hand
this is a little baby inside a hair so
when I find hair on my face here which
you can't see well I shaved I went like
this and in between my fingerprint it's
the finest piece of hair and then what I
did I drilled a hole into the hair and
then the baby was made from a floating
fiber so when the sunlight comes through
the window you see those Little Fibers
floating I caught one of those I had to
make a tool so sharp to cut it so I'm
smashed up a diamond into little bits
and it's one of them that I used to
slice the shape of the baby this one
took me three months to get it right
because it kept going wrong all the time
I call this one the beginning
Willard's Beginnings were not easy his
talents developing while facing
challenges in the classroom before
autism was diagnosed in schools back in
the 60s and 70s the educational system
would neglect kids with learning
differences so I'm in autism which
wasn't diagnosed back then
kids were sort of Left Behind not
because of their own fault because the
teachers left them behind so if a kid
had any Talent you would never know
because it was discouraged but one thing
I've learned is
I never got bitter I got better when I
was 15 I had a microscope this guy
directed me from school and I used to
break bits of razor blade off and pushed
him into a Matchstick and put a bit of
glue on them so I've got a little
scalper blade and things and then I
started getting little bits of
toothpicks and putting a bit some metal
into the end and holding things down and
slicing and as I got older I started to
evolve 55 years of doing this I'm now
65. so my whole life my whole body has
been trained that's the dedication that
I have
Willard's dedication makes him always
strive for perfection in his work the
emotional process is when it goes wrong
I'm pissed and then I sit down and I you
know it's not what you do when you get
knocked down it's what you do when you
get back up so if I get knocked down
with something I get back up and then I
find out why I got knocked down why why
it didn't work and I'll do it again and
I'll just keep going until I get it
right
how do you feel when you complete a
piece it's not a climbing a mountain
Mount Everest you get to the summit and
it's like
see my pleasure is looking at other
people you know seeing that their
reaction to know that inside the eye of
a needle has opened up the biggest world
to people
among these people entranced by
Willard's work was Queen Elizabeth II
the most proudest moment of my life I
had a letter from Buckingham Palace and
she'd accept my tiny microscopic crown
the queen came out and it was in the
beautiful microscope that's specially
made for her I took it showed it she
says this is fantastic it's so special
I've never had something so small that's
so special thank you very much shot in
my hand and I walked away thinking the
alarm clock was going to go off thinking
I'm going to wake up
what do you hope people take from your
work well I hope they see small things
in a much bigger way they look at life
different
if you see anything you can help the
person if you see a little bee on the
floor and he's walking pick him up put
him somewhere safe
there's kids out there with autism take
time to listen to them understand them
because they're diamonds in a Dustbin
take the lid off the bin and see what's
in there what Society seems to throw to
one side they'll realize they made a big
mistake
foreign